trois heures par jour c'est le temps que
passent les jeunes âgés de 3 à 17 ans
devant la télévision
une addiction que l'on croit récente et
pourtant retour dans les années 70 et si
tu pouvais choisir entre faire du sport
et regarder la télévision
regardez intelligent et oui dès les
années 70
l'amour passionnel des écrans étaient
pointés du doigt enfin deux l'écran car
il n'y en avait qu'un la télévision les
études que nous avons faites montrent
que les enfants de 6 à 10 ans en france
regarde la télévision en moyenne 10
heures par semaine bien entendu il y a
des différences selon les catégories
socioprofessionnelles selon l'âge bien
sûr les enfants de 10 à 14 ans regarde
d'encore beaucoup plus puisqu'on arrive
à des chiffres de l'ordre de 16 heures
17 heures par semaine
à l'époque tout comme aujourd'hui
certains parents à assumer complètement
le concept de la télé nourrissent les
journalistes multipliait alors les
sujets et s'adressait directement aux
enfants
est-ce que tu regarde la télévision ah
oui bah chez beaucoup souvent ou très
souvent combien de fois par semaine au
tous les soirs jusqu'à que leurs os ça
dépend jusqu'à la fin du film
dans les années 80 les craintes
d'addiction augmente car il ya plus de
chaînes plus de programmes jeunesse et
des enfants toujours plus coaché va
venir chercher ta télé
ce vol était pour golasa t'embête
convient de chercher ta télé howie des
menaces mises à exécution en 1986 par
des journalistes d'antenne 2 et de
télérama
afin de mesurer la dépendance aux tubes
cathodiques
ils font l'expérience de retirer la
télévision du salon de 22 familles
pendant un mois
résultat pour les adultes savent assez
bien pour les enfants ça va moins bien
su qu'à huit ans il supporte carrément
mal le mercredi après-midi santé
médicaux substance a été nul
les enfants accros à la télé une drogue
qui va être remplacée par une autre
les écrans de smartphones de tablettes
et ordinateurs dans les années 2010 la
télé tant aimée est alors remisé au
placard
je prends un tableau des besoins ok la
tablette de pêche fois la toile qui rend
encore plus dépendants car si les
enfants de 10 à 14 ans des années 70
regarder la télé
17 heures par semaine aujourd'hui les
ados de 15 ans ont les yeux rivés sur
les écrans
huit heures par jour
[Musique]